[Applause]
[Music]
trump's approach towards russia has been
one of the most controversial parts of
his short time in office so far it seems
that the u.s president wants to develop
a new friendship with this old rival
the thing is that this isn't proving so
easy and that's because beijing
is standing between them russia putin
moscow without any doubt one of the most
controversial issues is the fascination
trump seems to have with russia and its
charismatic leader vladimir putin
insinuations messages of support of the
election of senior officials who were
close to the kremlin he has met with
russian president vladimir putin
and the kremlin gave him the order of
friendship in 2013.
the new administration the way it is
being shaped right now
it is absolutely a gift for putin he
couldn't have dreamed about anything
like that just few months ago the
question
really is is trump trying to seduce the
russian leadership or
as some are saying is there something
suspicious about this developing
relationship it would be fair to say
that trump's approach to russia could
have an
explanation according to some analysts
advisors in the white house may have
told trump to try to be remembered
and make history by being the leader who
has the same success with russia as
nixon and kissinger had with china
nixon seduces mao's china
on the 21st of february 1972 one of the
most
important events in decades took place
that day
richard nixon arrived in beijing it was
the first ever visit to communist china
by a u.s president
[Music]
the big step for nixon an unknown step
for mankind
the entire trip was broadcast around the
world and it was
major major news millions of people held
their breaths as they saw nixon
descending the stairs of air force one
and setting foot
in the chinese capital city generations
in the years ahead will look bad
and thank us for this meeting that we
have held in this past week
but before we continue let's actually go
back a bit and see what this visit
really meant
what were the goals of this visit and
what made it possible so we're going to
travel back in time to october the 1st
1949. this was the day that china was
declared
the people's republic of china the
communists led by mao had won the
chinese civil war
and they took power of this new country
this new regime
was completely hostile to washington dc
in fact only a year later troops of the
chinese army participated in the korean
war to support pyongyang's regime
therefore confronting the u.s
face to face
[Music]
as a result of this bitter and violent
fight and its thousands of casualties on
each side there were no intentions of
establishing any diplomatic relations
it would be fair to say that from that
time on china and the us
were enemies what the hell these chinese
have to move in this neighborhood for
[Music]
in the meantime though relations between
beijing and moscow were very very
different
it is true that mao had never got on
with the soviet leaders who had by the
way supported other people to be the
leader of the chinese communist party
however despite all of these differences
a russian chinese alliance was almost
inevitable
on the one hand the soviet union needed
to control or at least
influence the other great communist
power on the other hand mao's china
desperately needed the ussr for economic
technological as well as military
support the support was so generous in
fact that between the year 1954
and 1959 the ussr spent seven percent of
the government's resources assisting
china some even say that this was the
largest technological transfer
in history
[Music]
now despite all of this differences
started to emerge in almost
every part of their relationship and the
alliance got weaker and weaker
until well it completely broke apart
relations were getting very tense first
there was the assault of the ussr's
embassy in beijing in 1967
and then the first armed encounter took
place in 1969.
the casualties were numerous during this
fight and a few days later the soviets
bombarded chinese troops deployed in the
area the conflict didn't go any further
but for days there was a feeling in the
air that this could be the start of a
significant war
moscow even considered sending troops
from the warsaw pact countries which
romania objected to
it is also said that in order to prevent
a potential nuclear attack by russia
nixon contacted moscow to make it
perfectly clear that the u.s
would never accept something like that
happening under any circumstances
[Music]
in the end relations between these two
communist nations broke down completely
at the time both nixon and his famous
national security advisor henry
kissinger
decided to take a famous saying and make
it their own
[Music]
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
once they'd said it
they started to put it into action and
two years later nixon was in beijing
relations between the usa and china
moved on slowly
in fact it wasn't until 1979 with jimmy
carter in office that full relations
with the nation were established but the
truth is
that nixon's trip to china made room for
a period of successful relations between
the two nations
in 1972 bilateral trade between the two
nations didn't even reach a billion
dollars today the number is close
to 600 billion
the relations have been relatively
friendly and the u.s also made a solid
ally against the soviet union during the
cold war
and this according to some analysts is
what trump is trying to achieve
with russia to reenact nixon and
kissinger's strategy for beijing
but with moscow this would explain the
pro-russian attitude of the current
president
however things are very much different
now than they were in 1969
[Music]
the romance between china and russia
relations between china and russia have
started to improve since the end of the
1980s
with some treaties and agreements being
signed here and there but it all changed
when xi
jinping came to power in 2012. since
then relations have advanced
quickly consider what was said in 2016
by one of the major players in the
chinese government
the profundity and the level of
coordination between both countries has
reached a level we have never seen
before
and beijing seems to be certain about
one thing an alliance between china
and russia would be very powerful from
any perspective today
both countries are cooperating like they
have never cooperated before
[Music]
in 2016 russia became the first chinese
oil supplier with oil that arrives by
land
this is something incredibly important
for china because in the case of a
conflict the u.s would be unable to
block the oil arriving
something it could do if that oil is
arriving by sea
[Music]
also both countries have started to
conduct joint military exercises they've
also created economic and technological
bonds and have agreed to carry out
projects to build infrastructure which
will connect both countries
so how about some examples of this well
let's have a look at three first the
military exercises
russia and china have begun eight days
of naval drills in the south china sea
second those economic bombs
and third infrastructure and for this
one what better example
is there than after 28 years of talks
construction has finally started on a
bridge between
china and russia
but there is more these two countries
have signed important military
agreements
china has committed to spending billions
of dollars to buy some of the most
modern equipment that the russian army
has
such as the s-400 surface-to-air missile
and the most impressive weapon in the
russian arsenal the sukhoi-35 fighter
aircraft just
have a look at this incredible machine
further to this there are also many
economic political and monetary
agreements all of this has led to
quite a lot of concern in the united
states
[Music]
press to their chinese russian affair
now just sit tight there for just a
second before you start to get scared
because
everything isn't quite as idyllic as it
sounds both powers may have come
together but there are still
many elements that separate them or
might potentially weaken this unity for
one
china wants to be important and
influential in international politics
and that implies becoming the leader of
central asia
this is something that russia certainly
doesn't want in their view the ex-soviet
states in the region
have to remain under the influence of
moscow further there are issues
concerning their economic relations the
trade is unbalanced in favor of russia
russia has become a supplier of natural
resources to china for the last few
years
while china has been supplying russia
with chinese manufactured goods which
are more valuable you see china's
position towards international trade
is very pragmatic chinese people want to
make money so they know it's good for
them to open their market to the world
this is simply an idea that russia
doesn't share
and then there is the issue with some of
russia's partners like india russia is
the largest weapons supplier in india
and obviously beijing doesn't like that
at all
so even though these two countries are
trying to get closer
and are supporting each other against
the us we shouldn't
expect a very solid relationship between
them after all china
is eventually going to make a play to
become the leader in this relationship
and
russia isn't just going to lie down and
accept that
[Applause]
[Music]
a feasible one to be honest it doesn't
seem very likely that re-enacting
nixon's strategy is possible
this is largely because china is going
to strongly oppose this relationship but
despite this if trump wants to earn the
trust of moscow he will have to make
some concessions which would be
difficult to accept in washington
elimination of sanctions giving in on
the ukraine and syria
the end of the anti-missile shield among
others putin is very demanding and even
if a good relationship is established
between russia
and the united states it is not clear
whether this alliance would be very
effective at actually stopping china
this is one reason why obama preferred a
strategy of surrounding china by
reaching agreements with the country's
neighbors
india vietnam malaysia and in this
strategy the tpp was key
and i say was of course because it was
one of the first things that trump
blocked when he arrived in the white
house
only time is going to be able to tell
whether trump's strategy is going to
work out but right now
it's not looking very promising so
that's our opinion here at visualpolitik
and we would now love to know what you
think do you think a chinese russian
alliance is going to be consolidated
against the usa or do you think trump
will succeed in a nixon-like
relationship with moscow let us know in
the comments below and if you did like
this video please
do give it a like it really helps us out
and do subscribe for brand new videos
just like this
every week that's on mondays and on
thursdays so hit that subscribe button
below
and thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you